is even worse than that because she not
only got revenge on her bullies but also
killed innocent people attacking in
self-defense is okay but that's not
what's going on here if we were to take
telekinetic abilities out of the
equation here for a moment this is
essentially a school shooting nobody is
out there saying that the Coline
Shooters did the right thing by shooting
up their school because they were
bullied so why are people saying that
about Carrie I'm guessing it's because
in the movie the story is told from
car's point of view we see the bullying
and I think it's normal to feel bad for
her I'm guessing a lot of people who
said Carrie have been bullied themselves
at some point and they were able to
share in her frustration and want to
protect her because they relate to her
in some small way and I think there's
just a little bit of a disconnect here I
can understand thinking that the
antagonist deserves some kind of
punishment and maybe some people got
that mixed up with saying that Carrie
was in the right